luna crashed and burned 32 billion
dollars but the question is now what
what is the fallout from all that today
we're going to find out we're gonna talk
about what happened to dokuan where all
that bitcoin they owned went and i'm
gonna finally answer the question is
luna coming back no sorry that's the
answer no no no stop dumping money into
this piece of trash panties uh sorry
about that guys uh still a little salty
about this one anyways let's jump into
luna armageddon uh we have uh sort of a
something called a protocol armageddon
at the company
so what protocol armageddon is that's a
kill switch
so whenever we feel like we're no longer
in a position to be able to best serve
the community
we pulled the trigger and 24 hours were
gone
we burn all of our assets we we caught
all of our ties and it's nothing hey you
probably thought i was clickbaiting you
with this title didn't you be honest all
right
no actually the founder of luna
literally said he had an armageddon
protocol
this guy knew
this ship was going down he planned for
it he bragged about those plans and as
more and more clips are just coming out
it turns out the warning signs have sort
of always been there people just ignored
it because they were making money and
that in of itself
should scare you because it might remind
you of something if you're paying
attention u-s-t-u-s-t
[Music]
u-s-t
u-s-t
all right guys now i feel like the big
connect guys
so big connect 2.0 that's the luna story
and obviously with hindsight bit connect
was so clear but watching the luna
disaster it's much easier to see why
people were fooled and you can see luna
influencers still trying to spin it one
way or the other oh it crashed because
the big banks wanted us to fail or it
crashed because of the haters no the
founder of luna knew this thing was
going to collapse and he said publicly
it was destined to go to zero it's a
cycle of life
you begin from nothing and go back to
nothing
that's exactly where i want to be
so i think pera is going to be the
decentralized money standard across the
entire blockchain
across all the blockchains
and i'm excited for care for that so
contributes a significant portion of
that early vision
but eventually to go back
to nothing right yeah excited so yeah
dokuan is trash and the people defending
him are either bag holders or also trash
and if you're not convinced at this
point that this guy is a grade a scammer
i just want to show you his other failed
algo stable coin basis cash which he
helped create according to coindesk now
this is how he talked about his own
project back when no one knew he was a
part of it quote while defy djinns are
busy trapping retail in zero-sum games
in basis cash and then another coin
called empty set squad now right there
take the screenshot upscale it to 4k
that's all the proof you need this guy
literally called his own project a trap
for retail investors and a zero sum game
and this is why when do kwan is later
going to apologize i have no time for it
i'm not interested he wants to save his
own skin and it's just
it's too little too late now we've
already learned a lot about dokuan so
now we're going to pivot to talk about
luna because since we last reported the
lunacoin has kept falling in value it is
now worth less than a penny which
probably has upset the degenerate
gamblers who have predictably been
throwing money at it hoping for a
thousand x gains by buying at the bottom
and like many degenerate gamblers most
of these traders don't understand that
things can always get worse they also
don't understand math many of them
because this person says easy 4 million
if luna reaches a dollar but because
luna has hyper inflated to 6.5 trillion
luna compared to only 300 million 10
days ago if luna were to hit one dollar
it would be worth five times more than
the entire global crypto markets
it's not going to happen now on the
other hand many luna investors aren't
delusional they're just angry so angry
in fact that one of them decided to
allegedly break into dokwan's house
in south korea which obviously is
disgusting and i don't endorse a
vigilante justice in any of this but
what i can endorse and do endorse is a
different group of investors who
unfriended their buddy after he got them
to put their life savings into luna he
says quote my friends who i recommended
luna to all hate me now which i think is
a fair exchange for life savings now in
response to this guy losing friends the
uk government decided that they were
going to finally step in and regulate
stable coins actually that's probably
not right but uh let's pretend it is for
the sake of this segue a treasury
spokesman for the queen said in a
statement the government has been clear
that certain stable coins are not
suitable for payment purposes as they
share characteristics with unbacked
crypto assets clearly targeting the
lunacoin here but i think the broader
lesson is just that algorithmic stable
coins don't work they're like a
perpetual energy machine or snl being
funny in 2022
it's a nice idea
but it just doesn't work in practice but
of course that won't stop them from
trying and luna and do kwan are busy
trying to save themselves in a
last-ditch effort this started with
dokuan apologizing for quote the pain
his invention has brought upon all of
you now as i said earlier i think this
apology is basically worth as much as
luna is right now which is worthless but
the real news is what do kwan said next
he proposed a recovery plan for the
terra ecosystem he calls it the terra
ecosystem revival plan 2. now like the
rest of dokwan's ideas
it's kind of terrible in fact i don't
think you could think of a worse
proposal basically i'll explain it the
idea is to fork the terra block chain
into a new chain called terra and
they're going to rename the old chain to
terra classic what's new well
not much it's the same old tara except
this time without stable coins which is
weird because the whole purpose of terra
was stable coins and that's their
business model i mean look you don't
even have to take my word for it just
listen to their first youtube video uh
tera is a price stable cryptocurrency
that is pegged to uh several of the
world's major fiat currencies such as
the usd the korean wan
the cny the gbp and most notably the imf
sdr so the goal is uh to connect all of
these stable currencies with the
e-commerce and
retail payment network such that you can
break down the barriers in international
commerce i mean that's their whole
shtick stable coins tara and their coin
luna without stable coins is nonsensical
it doesn't even make sense
and they say that the reason they're
trying to save it is this quote the
terra ecosystem and its community are
worth preserving terra's app ecosystem
contains hundreds of developers terra
station has a large install base and
although distressed strong brand
recognition and a name that almost
everyone in the world will have heard
about now while it's great and all that
everyone's heard of you the reason
everyone's heard of you is because you
fell apart luna has become the poster
child for crypto ponzi's going bust and
that's not exactly going to inspire
confidence no matter how much you tell
yourself all publicity is good publicity
as for the developer front the reason so
many people wanted to work on terra is
because there was so much money coming
in billions of dollars in fact
developers aren't charity workers
they're not going to just stay on a
project that's hopelessly lost its way
and deviated from its core promise
stable coins so forgive me if i'm a
little skeptical it's like if theranos
said they're ditching the whole blood
testing thing to become a steve jobs
look-alike merch company
it's just not going to work and if i
sound like i'm being critical i want to
say a lot of other people think this
plan is also equally a disaster in fact
the ceo of binance tweeted smh and said
this won't work forking doesn't give the
new fork any value that's wishful
thinking and finally he brings up a
super important question he says where
is all the bitcoin that was supposed to
be used as reserves and this is a really
important question i mean the whole
reason luna was supposed to be
unbreakable and you could have
confidence in it was this 80 000 bitcoin
they bought that they were going to
defend the peg with and so
later luna foundation guard actually
posted that update and they said well
they spent it it's gone 80 000 bitcoin
down the drain trying to buy ust
all in vain now i should say tara was
accused of bailing out crypto whales
with this money and opposed by the new
money review but lfg denies insiders
were bought out and since no real proof
has come out either way i'm gonna
withhold judgment until i get more
evidence that's what i said when
blackrock and citadel were accused with
no evidence and that's what i'm going to
say now when luna is accused of market
manipulation with
frankly not enough evidence we just
don't know yet and at the same time it
also kind of doesn't matter either way
luna doesn't really have any money left
and that's why it puts them in a weird
position when they claim they want to
help small investors and compensate them
they say this in a tweet but given that
they've spent the vast majority of their
money it's a bit like offering someone a
ride when you're out of gas still the
crypto community is very enthusiastic
about a bailout and i have to say
i find it kind of ironic people
rediscovering why basic financial
regulation exists in the first place i
mean vitalik the founder of ethereum
called for quote coordinated sympathy
for the average ust smallholder in the
form of a bailout and then he cited
american federal fdic insurance as
president which is just like
this is federally backed programs
created by congress like you can't have
it both ways you can't be
anti-centralization when it suits you
and then the moment everything goes
south be like
yo but that bailout though i mean don't
get me wrong i'm very pro crypto
regulation but it's just kind of amusing
watching people rediscover things that
already have existed anyways that's
basically what i wanted to talk about
pump the stock and thanks for watching